for a guy like you who you know
eventually needed something to get some
help with like an antidepressant and
stuff I can't imagine the [ __ ] you went
through when you first took over uh late
night if you and I wasn't on anything
then I wasn't no that's what I'm saying
You must have been so depressed people
were attacking you yeah trying to make
them laugh I didn't have the knowledge
that I had today
um
and uh there were yeah some
really really dark moments and the one
that comes to mind is
it was we were just on the air for like
two or three months
and things weren't going well and and
then I did uh Charlie Rose's Show when
he went we were probably aware of what
came out in the Washington Post today
the top TV critic in the world just
wrote this piece and here's what it says
and it goes and and it was a brutal
takedown just absolutely brutal takedown
of Me Andy the comedy everything and
this was back when I mean today
I don't know that TV critics move the
needle but back then it would be like
this could this could end everything
what was it like Tom shales or yeah it
was Tom shales and so and I didn't think
he was wrong I mean I was I was very raw
and I think I was such a letterman fan
still am that even then I always say if
I hadn't been me I would have hated me
because I would have been like you can't
yeah but the bigger part of the story is
what's Charlie Rose's agenda okay you're
there to celebrate what you're doing and
when he was being a journalist I guess
he read this thing to me and so I'll
never forget I leave
and we're somewhere here in Midtown not
far from where I am now we get in like
this town car me and my people Everyone
is silent we get to work and I quietly
go to my office and no one in the office
is saying anything and I go into my
office and I shut the door and I had
this I still have it in storage
somewhere all the years I was at late
night all those 16 years I had like an
iron desk that anybody would have it
just came with the office which I think
before I had it was not Dave's office it
was like an insurance company right and
I got on the floor and I climbed
underneath the desk and just lay there
and at one point after a while my uh
someone on the show leaned in and saw
just my legs coming out from underneath
the desk and then the next thing I know
Jeff Ross my executive producer is just
leaning in going like you okay uh
feeling all right and I under the from
underneath the desk I just said I'm fine
I just need to lie here under the desk
for a while
I'll I'll start having meetings in like
10 minutes but that was that to me is
like when the needle got to the lowest
when I was yeah and you don't have a
therapist at that point you don't have
an antidepressant at that point and I
know that level of shame but Charlie
Rose that is such an interesting thing
because he's he's it's almost like he
took you out in the middle of the Town
Square and clogged you you know man Lord
does he expect you to say gee yeah I
think I yeah but you know it's funny I
mean first of all I don't hold it
against him I really don't I and I and
he was uh nice to me I think he went on
to say well anyway I you know right
that's what they say but that's not what
I think
um look do I wish he hadn't read that on
the air sure but uh you know that was
another day at work for him and I don't
that doesn't get to me and I and now I
it's so funny I don't know how you feel
about this however but
I get to this point and I've had these
famous highs and lows and highs and you
know
I wouldn't change anything
I remembered my dad at the time said a
really smart thing he said if you can
survive this it's going to make the
whole story that much better